hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we're talking about side
hustles yes side hustles just because
you're making 100k a year doesn't mean
you wouldn't want another 10 000 a year
2 000 a year 500 bucks a year you know
and i know there are some that a lot of
people have here all the time and so i'm
actually going to make sure to really
start off with unique ones that you may
not have heard before really all the
tips i'm going to give you all can be
done by yourself or
with in partnership with a specific
company or agency so let's get to it
number one one great side hustle that
you can get into is administering mock
interviews a mock interview is basically
a fake interview designed for people who
are looking to get practice in for their
interviews whether it be behavioral or
technical get that real time practicing
and talk with another person a lot of
times people can't talk to their moms
their brothers or a mirror like they
need an actual person to stay
accountable i really like this one for
two reasons one you get paid you know
that's great when you get paid and two
if you are a person who you know you're
about to start job hunting or you just
want to find ways to develop your skill
sets this can be a great way to do so by
making sure that you are prepped for
helping this person you're also
bettering your own development skills
there are a thousand ways to complete
the exact same problem and so even if
you already know the ins and outs or you
think you already know the ins and outs
and you think you know the exact way to
solve the problem and whatnot the people
may surprise you and teach you a little
something which is great getting paid
and also getting that self-development
and learning as well and so this you can
very much do it by yourself you can say
yo i am nia and i am administering mock
interviews for 40 dollars for 30 minutes
or for an hour which is actually pretty
good because mock interviews can cost
anywhere from like 65 to like 150
dollars and so no
that actually is a pretty great maybe i
should do it that sounds like a pretty
great rate and so you can do that or you
can go and sign up on more quan quote
legitimate websites and businesses
however there obviously would be cuts to
the amount you make because they too
need to make money the second side
hustle that you very much can get into
is domain flipping now this is so domain
flipping slash like not so domain
flipping i'm sure especially if you're a
software engineer or interested in the
tech field you probably know what it is
well i'll give you a definition anyway
so domain flipping is you buy up a
domain name so i don't even know
google.com is not yet a thing and you're
like you know what would be
a cool domain name is google so you can
use sites like godaddy or bluehost you
don't have to buy it now but you can
just see if it's available through sites
like those and a bunch of numerous other
sites and you type it in and you see oh
wow it actually is not taken well would
you look at that and you may have you
know may have come from the feature and
think you know what this is going to be
worth
a lot of money one day let me purchase
this domain name for one dollar a month
yeah domain names can be as low as one
dollar a month two dollars a month
depending on the name and how you know
popular um it seems to be and so you're
like you know what okay one dollar a
month i think i can squeeze it and you
press purchase and there you go you now
are the owner of google.com
now three days later we'll look at that
your timing was impeccable three days
later
a person will call him i don't know
larry
larry is like you know what yes the name
of this new company is going to be
called google he looks up to see if the
domain name is available and he sees it
is not well cry not larry because you
can purchase the name from little billy
bob over there for
x amount of dollars and you can set the
amount of dollars you want to sell it
for and whatnot and you can end up
making
a solid amount of cash now of course you
probably are not going to magically
stumble upon a domain name that just
happens to be the same name of a
multi-billion dollar company and whatnot
but you get the idea by simply buying up
names that you think could be used in
the future by people looking to start
companies or just get personal pages for
themselves you can actually earn a solid
amount of change i personally have
purchased domain names that i don't
really plan on using um and i just
looked before this video and they are
worth between four hundred dollars and
thirteen hundred dollars depending on
the name i have a couple and depending
on the name they are worth in that range
now there's another side to this if you
stumble upon the domain name that you're
actually kind of like shocked it's not
taken so let's say it's a trending topic
or something that's just been
very apparent right now specifically you
can purchase it and then choose to just
set up google adsense and so now when
people go onto your one page and google
adsense is there now you earn money from
that and meanwhile while you are holding
on to this domain name the domain can
actually be ramping up in value in the
meantime and so you can be earning that
passive income while also in the
background is increasing in value and so
there are two ways to do this and so i
highly suggest at least looking at it so
the third side hustle that i kind of
just stumbled upon i didn't really
realize how much i could make doing it
until i really just yeah stumble
department is qa testing for apps apps
that people have developed and they are
looking to see how other users interact
with it get insight and information from
a user perspective of what the ui is
like what the u x user interface and the
user experience
feels like because when you're a
developer and you're so
deep into something it gets kind of
difficult to
have that hat on of okay but how will
the user interact with this how will the
user feel with this or because you've
worked with something for so long you
don't notice the little things that
again users would i've done user testing
a couple of times now and i remember i
noticed this one thing with an app let's
say i'm user testing for amazon.com i
want a new computer and now there's the
whole list of computers i saw that
i had to click on the specific name of
the computer to get to the next page
instead of clicking the general area the
computer was on because the
card of the computer if you're a
software engineer you know what i mean
by card if you're not then really i mean
the general area of the computer i was
looking at and so yeah clicking the
picture it didn't go to the page looking
around it didn't click didn't go to that
page i had to select the specific words
of macbook air in these
little tiny fonts for it to go on the
page and so that was one of the first
things i brought up because i
did not like it at all it's things like
this that developers want to hear and so
yeah i did this a couple of times if you
look up just things like craigslist and
linkedin and google and look up qa
testing for apps and web apps you
definitely can find something it's also
kind of fun to do it was fun to
be so nitty-gritty i'm a very
detail-oriented person so it's fun to
look at this really cool idea for an app
and go through it all and then just
communicate my findings and call it a
day instead of having to be the one to
now fix it i spent about 10 to 20 hours
on both projects total not per week or
anything just total and got a couple of
hundred dollars from them and so this
can also be a great way to go the next
thing you can do is tutor the thing with
becoming a software engineer
especially
not from a university is
i feel like i mean please tell me if i'm
wrong i'd love to be wrong but i feel
like the resources available for people
to get extra live help not help via the
internet via
stack overflow and all of these
different sites but live one-on-one help
they're pretty small and so you can be a
tutor you can say like yo i am
proficient in these things in these
languages let me know if you need a
tutor and let me know if you're
self-teaching if you're in a coding boot
camp one hour session would be this
amount and let's call it a day and so
that could also be really really great
the
only problem problem qualco problem with
this is maybe the
work you're putting into it because you
really have to be attentive and um
provide at a great service because yo
you're
you may be the deciding factor between a
person passing their coding challenges
and assignments in a person you know not
and so you really i would hope you want
to be focused and so because of that it
can feel a lot more strenuous than other
side hustles however they can it can
also be the most fulfilling side hustle
because you're developing these
relationships again you yourself could
be learning with this person teaching is
a great way for you to learn yourself
especially when you know oh so i'm going
to be teaching this subject tomorrow so
let me go and make sure i'm good on it
myself and now you're doing studying
beforehand and learning new things as
well and so it can be the most
fulfilling thing and such a great way to
have your own personal and professional
development and it can you can make
quite a lot of money y'all seriously you
can make quite a lot of money again
especially because there are so few
resources out there for live one-on-one
help for people not in the college
system and if you know having a person's
future in your hands is not you know
your cup of tea then you can also go the
solo route just doing your own freelance
work i know people i've heard this time
and time again and i'm going to be the
you know last one to share it to round
out this video but i can't have this
video without
the
known to all
side hustle of freelancing your skills
as a developer
they are quite priceless and don't think
you need to be the world's best
developer to be able to freelance your
services because people and especially
people outside of the tech world they
see tech as this
big dark cloud that they want nothing to
do with and so they are willing to pay
top dollar for the most
basic of pages and sites and web apps
and so don't shy away from it just
because you think you're not an expert
and so don't knock it at least don't
knock it for that reason but there we go
everybody like i it is 2021 we are
where we are and so i wanted to yeah
provide you all with some tips and
insights of side houses you can do to
keep things interesting to keep things
fresh and keep some money in your wallet
and gain that personal and professional
development for yourself as well so i
hope this was helpful please let me know
if it was like subscribe and i'll see
you all later bye